the jurgen experience how was it uh
working with brian ortega
uh to be honest mate he doesn't say much
he doesn't say much look here i don't
know like yeah we're
we're i'm i'm a bit over him to be
honest
yeah just uh a couple of things you know
what i mean like
i just think he's fake i think he's uh
he's fake and i don't believe you [ __ ]
so
that's just sort of how it is with me
that's what i think when you say fake
like in what way is he fake
oh man just uh yeah i just think you
know he plays plays a nice guy and some
of the [ __ ] he says like i just think
it's all [ __ ]
but uh yeah i guess you can watch the
show and like sort of see you like with
little things but
i know just even with a couple of things
like i don't think he's that bad of a
guy maybe i'm just looking for things to
hate on him
i'm sure you're maybe yeah probably you
know what i mean so i'm just sitting
there be like nah [ __ ] brian will take
you know i mean i'm gonna find something
to hate him for but
uh you know maybe that's what it was but
i mean like still yeah uh little things
i was just like yeah but i mean
like i said it's not hard to get under
his skin even me just saying that i
guarantee he's boiling up so
maybe that's going to be strategy for my
next fight because i know how easily
he's triggered so i'm just going to be
like hey
brian [ __ ] you that's it
when are you when are you guys scheduled
to fight at the end of the series
well yeah yeah so when it is yeah so uh
from what i'm told i don't know if i'm
going to get in trouble saying this i'm
not sure but i think it is like
september
early september so you'll be fighting
him sometime in september and that will
be
in the united states uh yeah i'm
guessing yeah yeah
nice interesting it's um it's a great
fight
like if you look at the fight on paper
especially after his fight with the
korean zombie it's fun fight to watch
yeah he definitely uh definitely looked
good in that fight he surprised me in
that fight too he definitely uh
changed his game a little bit and then
fought a a different fight that i wasn't
expecting
but uh but again you know you know i'm
confident in my abilities i just i just
believe i'll be too much and
the beauty the beautiful thing about it
i can say what i want but i get to prove
it soon so
you know i i wish i got to prove it
march when i was scheduled to fight but
obviously that didn't happen but you
know i'll i'll prove that very uh
soon anyway so it's all good it's a
special division man that 145 is a
really special division because there's
so much talent there
it's uh i think it's hard to say what
the it's between
i think it's between 55 and 45 like the
most
amount of like real top level talent but
yeah
45 is just so filled so filled with guys
yeah there is there's a lot of guys that
come and even some of the guys that are
higher in the rankings like
just starting to come up like there's a
lot of dangerous guys and that's what
that's the beautiful thing about it like
that motivate motivates me i'm looking
forward to it you know these are the
guys i want
i want these guys that are people i love
being the underdog as well yeah even
though i'm champ
you're still gonna have the doubters and
all that and i love that you know what i
mean i want to be down to the
underdog and you know i want them
doubters and i love proving people wrong
you like being the underdog yeah i don't
know i do i do mean that
it's gotta be hard to be the underdog
when you're the [ __ ] champ yeah yeah
it's true i know but i mean i guess i
wouldn't say underdog but i mean the
doubters maybe right maybe yeah and i
use the doubters as
fuel right so i love it again i love
proving them wrong and
my if i was a underdog for this fight
you know i don't know if i would be but
i mean if i was i would not care one bit
i'd be like all right at least i get to
make my
my boys or whoever's betting on me more
money let's go you know i mean i'm more
good
now you guys were supposed to you were
scheduled to fight but then you got
coveted
and when you got coveted when you got
tested initially when you got tested you
didn't feel sick right
uh i mean before because we'll get
tested a fair bit
so i'm guessing before we went into the
bubble
i must have got it from someone or
whatever and then uh you know a few days
later we got tested a couple of times it
didn't pop
up but then we got tested yeah one of
the days
and that was like right at the end of my
camp like because i went there a bit
early to for brad riddell to corner or
be with him because he fought the week
before me so i did my last week of
training hard training
in vegas after traveling and doing all
that and then i got covered
uh must have had it uh trained like hard
you know
we get stuck into it so i did back to
back because the schedule
got tightened up because we arrived a
bit later in the week so uh
back to back really really solid
sessions while i probably had covered
uh so but i mean i sort of had started
again headaches and that before i was
like i'm getting headaches that's vegas
maybe
you know just dehydrated and whatnot but
but yeah then i tested positive and then
i started getting the symptoms after
that
and when you say like your schedule
tightened up so you guys have a very
rigid program that you follow no matter
what like
at this day you're doing this yeah
exactly so we got
you know we got a few hard sessions and
when i say hard sessions they're you
know they're
you know they're mind-blowing type of
sessions off for some people that that
will the watcher buddy you know that's
just
our schedule and uh usually you have
good rest in between them
and like that's you know you need to
have the rest you want good recovery so
you're able to do them you know and
this camp was beautiful we we did it
absolutely we nailed the camp man i was
doing some of the harder sessions but
i was recovering on point my recovery
was on point i was like man like you
know i'm getting older but i feel like
the camp's getting easier like how's
that happening right now
but uh that that week got tightened up
so i end up doing a couple of these
really really high
loaded sessions uh they end up being
like
back to back where usually i would have
like high low session high
low ceiling what was the decision what
made the decision to do high
back-to-back uh just
just again it was just more the fact
that uh
you know we just need to do a couple i
still don't think it was that but
i felt fine like while i was doing that
like i didn't think nothing of it but
i'm just
because i end up getting pretty rattled
from from the
the covet that's why i was like man like
maybe my immune system was down
you know at the end of the at the end of
camp obviously dieting and all that type
of stuff but
i felt fine but you know i'm pretty sure
i started feeling some of the symptoms
uh before i was getting into them hard
sessions as well yeah all the fighters
that i know that got it bad it was all
the same sort of situation when they
were
in camp really beaten up like cody
garbrandt same thing with
cody had coveted for probably weeks and
was training with it
yeah before he even got tested and and
then they're like bro you got covet and
he's like oh well that explains a lot
and then you know he was pretty [ __ ]
up for a few months but yeah he had
trained like
real hard like well that's that's
obviously gonna you know
play a big factor and you and the thing
is like you're here and then
you hear like the hazmat uh you know
sort of situations cody garbrandt
so like we wanted to keep an eye on it
but you know what i mean and that's why
we got it and then if i know you've got
the pneumonia
and then uh you know then the symptoms
are you felt the symptoms a fair bit
but then uh then i got that pneumonia
and then like the sort of the infection
just started getting a little bit worser
so i end up getting you know pink
coughing up like pinky bloody sort of
stuff and then
the blood just got more and more so then
we went back and that's when they they
got me on the medication and
and yeah because i was like coughing up
blood and all told how sick like how
long were you sick for
uh probably would have been maybe
ten days or something maybe luckiest
sundays like seven or ten days did they
do iv
vitamins or anything like that uh yeah
once once i was in the hospital they
were doing that yeah
but i mean as soon as i got on the
medication um you know for dexamethasone
i like made like just
improvements like straight away but
right now obviously i've got an ortega
to worry about and
watch this season and watch everyone
come watch me
stir him up and give him [ __ ] what is
the pressure like of hanging out with a
guy that you're
to fight for five weeks you're just
hanging out day in and day out
seeing each other all the time well we
talked about it i was talking about how
i adjust and adapt to things that
in front of me even in the fight i'm
just like that 24 7. you know i mean i'm
the type of guy that whatever i'm doing
that's it on me you know i forget i'm a
[ __ ] ufc champ i forget i'm a i'm
even a fighter half the time you know me
because once i'm home i'm daddy that's
it and that's a lot you know
but that's how i am but i went in there
and i just knew i ever won a
reality tv show he's going to be there
whatever but it was funny because again
you're trying to get reads on him and
and things like that but
again i just think he's [ __ ] awkward
he's an awkward dude
what do you reckon what did you get out
of here that's for sure he definitely
wasn't a fan of me by the end of the
show
really actually almost got fired for one
of the pranks i played on him but
we weren't allowed to uh what was that
you almost got fired or he almost got
i almost got fired for it was that
that was the code we had to take five
covert tests a week so obviously there's
pranks on the show this won't make the
tv show anyway but i did pretend to put
his cover test on my ass
the mouth the heart the mouth was it was
a dream it didn't really happen but uh
so we're pretending to piss on his uh
like you know his signs and all that
we've got photos of us like just
throwing up again a bit of
laugh you know a bit of banter but we
know how he carries on there was a photo
that he put
um you put it up didn't you of the keys
yeah we pretended to take his car
attending pretending we just had a photo
of the keys and uh
supposedly he had the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
and like he was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
craig i'm like i'm in the photo too why
aren't you saying you'll [ __ ] fight
me yeah he's like if he touches the car
or we'll fight him
but i mean again like whether whether he
was just like you know going along with
it or whatever it was but
or he's just easily triggered i i don't
know but like we
so we started realizing that so we just
we just started like playing on that a
fair bit and
hey knowing that he's easily triggered
there might be a route to this next
fight as well
what happened with the covid test swap
like you took a photo pretending that
you were sticking up come on can we get
this up
yeah yeah um air drop it to jamie get
the get the photo of us
out as well you guys are grown man
get the photo of us pissing yeah and the
thing with me with the thing up my ass
yeah
i get that mac pro jamie yep
uh mvp oh oh there it is something
happened
uh right okay but again just have a bit
of a laugh you know what i mean we will
uh that one
it's on the wrong computer
i mean it's pretty light-hearted you
know like i wouldn't really stick his
oral cover to about my ass
how could you even get a hold of it i
mean isn't that stuff controlled that's
what i don't understand like
where the [ __ ] is the nurse well i just
waited to the nurse
uh had to go to the bathroom you know
swab
there it goes oh my god
yeah that's actually that cheeky smirk
too late they actually almost fired me
for this one so i didn't
i probably probably crossed the line a
little too much but
remember this is a different swap just
in case you do still yeah this is
fake ladies and gentlemen it's just a
joke allegedly it might have been a
flavored test you never know
l-o-l um so
what did they say to you well i mean and
i did have some ideas for
some covert pranks because obviously
we're trying to get them but they did
tell me because they spent so much money
on cobra
testing they were like that's that's a
line we can't cross but
i just couldn't resist craig did it
anyway it was just sitting right here
that's probably not on the film
pull-out test was sitting in the same
section
yeah i get it listen makes sense to me
you got to do what you got to do but
that's part of the fun of the show right
it's [ __ ] with everybody
exactly
and the more conflict there is the
better the ratings are the better the
show does
better it is for everybody when you guys
have a big fight
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience